you do this thing that I just always
loved and I love it it's working so well
you take these sketches that you wrote
when you were to sound out live and you
couldn't get them on people thought
that's never gonna work and now that
you're John Mulaney you're saying I'm
back and we're doing that sketch they
let you do them and they've been
terrific they've been they really have
been true but I never I never walk in
and say I'm John Mulaney guess what I've
asked around
yeah I'll say you walk in with a
briefcase I'm John Mulaney and we're
doing these sketches filled with Sinatra
oh you did a diner lobster right yes I
wrote that with Colin Jost ill from that
I think just to remind everybody and
then you just did bodega bathroom say I
watched I watched bodega bathroom and
actually I one of my favorite parts was
when your bowtie fell off and you did
you lean you quickly leaned over and
just picked it up and put it in your
pocket like it wasn't gonna get in the
way of anything yes it could have we had
two turntables that the walls we've done
if it had gotten caught in there and the
walls started buckling you know people
could have been injured or worse so I
very stealthily except everyone noticed
grab the bowtie it wasn't that stealthy
you just you draw and then you go
I'm still it hard a writer not a
performer I better get the bowtie yeah
yeah I am I was loved those sketches and
then it had me thinking and I think a
lot of people online are wondering is
that a trilogy you don't I mean like you
you've taken you've taken there's
there's the diner there's the bodega and
they become these musicals are we gonna
see is there a third installment well
they are okay they're very specific New
York City observations that we turn into
musicals by stealing songs from other
musicals and I'm not sure what the next
would be I think it might be the G train
well you can tell why they were yeah
yeah everyone's waiting for this one
have you heard of the a train that
wasn't even enthusiastic right the G
train is a train with like three cars
that runs from Brooklyn to Queens and it
runs whenever it wants to
sometimes it's like yeah it'll be here
in 35 minutes and it's like a plane in
1924 it's like it might get here
the the the platform is so empty by the
way I used to smoke on the subway
platform and this was not like in 1940
this was in 2008 but the G train is it's
such a weird world of people and there's
always a seat that has a little level of
soda just sitting in it so that might be
the next inspiration but you know so we
can be looking for that again now that
I've said that out loud I guess I won't
host again